Just before you get cracking with today's video,
do you want to say there's obviously going to be a lot of Japanese pronunciation
in it?
As always,
I am doing my best.
If you'd like to have a good me anyway.
Do you use the comments?
That's what they're for.
So Hirohito,
he was the longest reigning monarch in Japan's history,
serving as emperor for 63 years,
vested with Supreme Power and viewed as a deity bias.
People.
He presided over a nation that's unleashed a war savagery that shocked the world
is unprecedented radio address to his nation,
announcing Japanese surrender in World War Two,
you start all of the people only to be followed with the bombshell that he was
not in fact a god,
but just a fallible man dress like the people in this week,
spine graphics video,
we go beyond the pump,
the ceremony to discover the man who was emperor Hirohito.
By the middle of the 19th century,
the emperor of Japan had become a title in name only.
The emperor was merely a figurehead with no real say in matters of states been
changed with the ascension to the throne.
If he 120 seconds,
Emperor Meiji,
Meiji embarked upon a series of political reforms that brought about an era of
enlightened rule by the time of his grandson,
the future Emperor Hirohito his birth,
the cult of the emperor.
It was already well established.
Laws had been inactive for bidding any criticism of the emperor.
The birth of Emperor Meiji First Grandson on April the 29th,
1981 was a time of rejoicing throughout the empire.
The infant was given the title Prince Michi.
He was named Hirohito,
which comes from a Chinese saying that roughly translates to when society is
wealthy.
The people are content area.
He did.
His father was the 21 year old Crown Prince Akihito.
It was slightly built and he was constantly unwell.
His mother was the 16 year olds princess,
so docker as was the custom among Japanese royals.
The child was taken from his parents and raised by a surrogate.
It was decided by the emperor that his grandson be raised by a retired military
officer in order to provide the mental toughness and discipline that would be
needed for his future of role as emperor.
The man that was chosen was counts cower Mara summit,
Yoshi,
a retired vice admiral.
The emperor told tomorrow to raise Hirohito as if he were his own grandson,
Carramar right,
raised the infants that is mentioned in the hills outside of Tokyo when he was
14 months old.
Hirohito was drawings by his younger brother,
Prince Yasuhito.
Every aspect of the children's lives was carefully overseen including the foods
they eat and the clothes that they wore,
but then in November of Nineteen,
oh,
four calmar had died and suddenly the two boys were reunited with their parents
that the crown princess I Yama Palace.
The boys were now attended by a series of nurses.
The main carer,
if Hirohito was a woman named at that sheet Tako,
who became his surrogate mother.
Hirohito,
develops into a sedate,
retiring,
and insecure Charles as would be expected.
He was fostered over and pampered from the moments he work each morning.
This did nothing to develop resilience and independence.
Even in play.
He was to be shown the Osmos reverence when he ends up the children of the royal
palace played war games.
He was always to take the role of the conquering general from the age of four
onwards.
Hirohito and his brother were indoctrinated into the military heritage of their
nation.
They will often taken some military parades and war museums to gaze upon the
swords of former heroes Hirohito.
His worldview was builds upon the belief that the entire past,
present,
and future of the great empire of Japan,
dependent on the wisdom of the emperor.
And so those few advises that he surrounded himself with at the age of seven,
Hirohito straining was put in the hands of a hero of the Japanese war named
General Nogi.
Nogi insisted on strict military discipline,
refusing to show any deference for the princess position.
Instruction centered on things that were considered essential in a future.
Emperor frugality,
patients,
diligence,
selfcontrol and manliness.
No,
he quickly made the young Hirohito come to the realization that he was
physically,
we can tap to work hard to develop physical strength.
As instructors,
uh,
Pierce College,
we're also told him to give special attention to guiding him in military
matters.
By the age of 11,
Hirohito had been imbued with a strong sense of reverence for his ancestors.
It was at that age that he officially became a crown prince.
He was also given the rank of second leftenant in the army a few months later,
and per meg died at the age of 61 and Hirohito.
His father in Paris had the supreme position in contrast to his own father,
Yoshi.
He's proved to be a weak and indecisive emperor.
As a result of visors came to have more and more sway in the royal court.
Yoshi did not involve himself in state affairs.
His grandfather's death marks a turning points in the life of the future.
Emperor,
a new phase of his training.
It was undertaken with the appointments of a military aid to come to chamberlain
between the ages of 13 and 19.
He was given a military and liberal arts education.
There's a school that had been specially built for him within the confines of
the tech and now a palace.
It was instructed by the brightest military minds in the lands.
Hirohito graduated from the school in Nineteen 21.
By this time,
he had developed a fascination with biology.
He liked nothing better than collecting seashells and small insects during the
school years as teacher of natural history.
It was a professor Hattori for the next 30 years.
The story acted as his sermons and all manner of scientific pursuits.
In 1921 hirohito visited Europe and making him the first Japanese crown prince
do travel abroad.
He was out of the country for six months visiting the United Kingdom,
France,
Italy,
Belgium,
and the Netherlands of this period.
He later wrote,
I knew freedom for the first time in England's every move that the young prince
made while on tour was covered.
Fever initially by the world's press having just returned from his overseas
excursion.
Hirohito was further into the limelight.
When his father retired his office due to mental illness,
the future emperor was now the regions he was to retain that this position until
his father died at the age of 23.
Hirohito married his distant cousin,
Princess Aco Cooney.
He did so against the advice of his advisors who considered her to be an
unsuitable match for the future.
Emperor two years later,
with the death of his father,
his regency ended and he became the emperor
Hirohito inherited the throne on December the 25th,
19,
26.
The 25 year old was now the 124th emperor of Japan.
This automatically meet him.
The commander in chief of the armed forces is able to give orders directly
without consulting the cabinets.
He also became the chief priest of the Shinto Religion,
guiding him in his new political life.
Hirohito was attended to by a seven member palace entourage of men,
much older than himself.
These gathered,
filtered and disseminated political information to the emperor.
Hirohito quickly established a vast network of informants who relayed
information to him on the going ons in every corner of governments,
even has a spy regularly reporting to him on the political activities of his
brother,
Prince Chichibu.
The new emperor was keen to stamp his footprints on the political landscape is
first acts was to announce a public holiday in remembrance of his grandfather.
Then in an effort to show solidarity with the peasantry during a time of
agricultural hardship,
he received at rice plants from all over the empire and staged a ritualistic
rice planting events within the palace grounds throughout the year.
Nineteen,
28 enthronement ceremonies and rituals were carried out in honor of the emperor.
The celebrations climaxed in November and December when hundreds of thousands of
people participated in banquets and awards ceremonies in the emperor's name.
Millions of men were given to the needy and thousands of prison sentences were
commuted.
The reign of Herod was designated as show up,
which means enlightened piece from the moments of as ascension.
The emperor was no longer to be referred to you by his given name,
but rather by the title,
His Majesty,
the Emperor Hirohito came to power during a time of economic hardship.
The crisis had led to the rise of political power of the military who now had
veto power over his cabinets.
Incidents of political violence were not uncommon.
In 1932,
the prime minister in your kit was assassinated and there was an attempt on
Hirohito his own life.
In 1932,
this incidence led to a dramatic curtailing of the emperors availability to the
public.
As Emperor Hirohito followed a disciplines routine.
He rose at 6:00 every morning to prepare for an English breakfast at seven.
Throughout the morning,
he would receive visitors,
enjoy a light lunch at midday,
and then spend the afternoon pouring over and signing documents,
everything to his marriage and the GEICO.
It was a happy one with their only source of anxiety being the failure to
produce an APP is advisors urged him to take a concubine,
but he resisted this advice,
the couple of ball three daughters before the heir to the throne,
Naca Hito.
In 1933,
the couple of wind zones,
you have a total of seven children.
Japan had enjoyed a level of unprecedented growth and prosperity during the 19
twenties.
In essence,
the country existed as a democracy during this period,
which lessens the influence of the military.
This came to an ends with the onset of the depression and during which time the
strong measures advocated by the military leaders began to gain ascendancy.
The unification of neighboring China also fed into the call for a strong
militaristic hands.
In 1931,
the military moved against civilian leaders,
but first they devised a plan to go to war with Manchuria by blowing up a
portion of the south Manchurian railway and they made on the Chinese.
This gave the pretext for an invasion of Manchuria.
The emperor Nazi mentioned the government was completely in the dark about any
of these goings on.
This set the scene for the 19 thirties.
This was a period during which the military pretty much accepts in an arbitrary
fashion when the army began a full scale invasion of China Hirohito orders that
they stop.
However,
the cabinet managed to persuade the emperor to acquiesce and allow this invasion
to proceed.
Hirohito felt powerless to reign in the army,
ever a fearful that doing so would result in his assassination.
In 1932,
he gave the go ahead for the bombing of Shanghai.
The assault was also approved by the Chinese leader Chiang Kai Shek,
who saw it as an opportunity to put down a rebel group who were based in
Shanghai.
The bombing and subsequent invasion led to tremendous loss of life,
unleashing worldwide condemnation.
Hirohito was worried that the Americans might respond militarily and told the
army to withdrawal again.
They ignored the commands of their emperor.
The Japanese went onto completely subjugate Shanghai by now mentioned area was
completely occupied and had become a Japanese state.
Many Chinese were simply put to death by the occupying force.
Once again,
this broad public condemnation with the League of nations condemning the
Japanese in response Japan resigned from the League,
despite the emperor is designed to remain within it,
unable to stop the withdrawal.
He insisted that his foreign minister of stress that Japan was determined to
work to achieve world peace throughout the 19 thirties spurred by the flexing of
its military muscle.
A sense of nationalism grew in Japan that saw a reverence for the Samurai
traditions,
volts.
All of this feeds into the worship of the emperor,
which was especially strong among the rank and file of the armed forces.
These soldiers viewed Hirohito as a god and pledged their lives to serve him.
In 1934,
Japan began to enlarge its navy and direct violation of the Washington Naval
Treaty of Nineteen 22 which had restricted it's science to three fifths of the
United States and Great Britain.
Yes,
again,
Hirohito was against the move,
but it was not strong enough to stand up to the military.
The flexing of military muscle came to a head in February of 1936 when their
records and uprising led by army officers.
Finally,
Hirohito acted decisively.
He ordered the immediate suppression of the revolts along with the execution of
its instigators,
Aaron.
He said it was powerless,
however,
to stop the growing power of the military.
By 1937,
the situation with China had developed into all out war era who had agreed to a
buildup of forces in occupied China in order to stem the tide of communism.
But he soon realized that hostilities were escalating uncontrollably and he
insisted that the army pulled back.
However,
the military bras,
they were not listening.
A full scale attack was made on the Chinese capital of Nan King.
In the wake of the subjugation of Nanking,
the Japanese Army unleashed an orgy of rape and murder that shocked the world
known as the rape of Nanking.
It resulted in the death of as many as 200,000 Chinese men,
women and children worldwide.
Condemnation for the atrocities of Nan King were heaped upon Japan,
still the armed forces forged on in their attempt to conquer China.
However,
the country was simply too large with the result of the Japanese military was
tied up in a hopeless mission on foreign soil.
For the next four years,
by the outbreak of the Second World War,
the combination of nationalism,
emperor worship and military control had forged a Japan into a nation that was
ready and eager to enter hostilities with other nations.
After all going to war was seen as doing the will of the emperor.
The reality was that Hirohito was opposed to the idea of his country going to
war.
He was a pacifist as heart since was cautious by nature,
but he was simply too weak.
Wills to control the reigns of a military that was chomping at the bit to exert
its controlled throughout the far east.
In September 19,
40,
Japan entered into a threeway alliance with Germany and Italy.
This gave the military leaders the confidence do extend its conquests in the Far
East.
The first victim would be the French colony of Indochina with the French already
having been beaten by Germany.
It was easy pickings.
The emperor,
however,
was opposed to the move on principle considering it to be like acting as a thief
in a fire.
In 1941,
Japan signs a nonaggression pact with the Soviet Union.
This gave the military the confidence do extend its occupation into southern
Indochina in response to the United States imposed tough sanctions on the
Japanese.
They also put an embargo on all oil exports to Japan.
This move forced Japan's hands with the results that the decision was made to go
to war with the United States.
As usual,
the emperor,
I felt powerless to stop this military juggernaut with the attack on Pearl
Harbor on December seventh,
19,
41 war was declared between the United States and Japan Hirohito,
though not opposing the plan,
the attack has always intended that Japan would declare war before striking.
You considered the surprise attack on Hawaii as dirty tactics and was extremely
upset with the military for the manner in which this attack was carried out with
a much longed for war now upon them all of Japan put their shoulder to the wheel
in support of victory.
Ironically,
the emperor who had never been an advocate of the war was looked to as the
champion of the Japanese war efforts.
During the first few months of 1942,
Japan won victory after victory.
Malaya Singapore at time,
but then a heavy blue was inflicted when an American bombing raid was unleashed
upon a number of key Japanese cities.
The Battle of midway was the first military defeats and things.
They simply never recovered.
By the end of 1944,
Japan's lost hopes rested with the kamikaze pilots who vowed to die for their
emperor by crashing their planes into American aircraft carriers,
but this was simply too little,
too late.
Hirohito was by now eager to see an end star civilities for the first time.
He involved himself in the planning of a battle.
If one would force,
the Americans do propose a peace settlement,
the resulting battle of Okinawa,
so some of the fiercest fighting of the entire war.
However,
the emperor has planned it backfired.
The American casualties were so high that they despaired that the Japanese would
ever surrender with American bombs decimating his key cities.
Hirohito was ready to put an end to the carnage,
but once again,
he was overridden by his military commanders who vowed to never surrender.
On August the sixth and ninth,
19,
45,
the Americans dropped atomic bombs on the cities of Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
Despite the terrible loss of life that resulted,
half of the prime minister's cabinet were opposed to a surrender.
The deadlock.
It was broken by the emperor.
On August the 15th.
The people of Japan heard the voice of their emperor for the first time.
He told them that Japan was surrendering to the allies in stating his reasons
for the surrender.
He said with reference to the atomic bomb,
that a continuation of the struggle would lead to the total extinction of human
civilization before most surrender took place on September.
The second is on board the USS Missouri,
Arizona did not have to suffer.
The indignity of attending Japan was now an occupied country under the
management of General Douglas Macarthur.
The emperor expressed a desire to advocate,
but he was persuaded to remain in place by macarthur.
Giving him on the throne would help to provide some semblance of normality.
As Japan emerged from the ashes of war,
the allies drew up a list of 28 top wartime leaders who are culpable of
committing crimes against humanity during the war,
and they put them on trial.
Hirohito,
though it was not among them,
still many pointed the finger at the emperor.
Surely if he was a god,
he could have stopped the atrocities
with announcing pressure.
Hirohito spoke to his people for a second time.
Over the radio or Lydia state in 1946 this time,
what he had to say was even more shocking than his announcement of the
surrender.
He was not a god he told the nation,
but just an imperfect human being just like them in the way of this bombshell
announcement.
His title was officially changed from imperial sovereign to constitutional
monarch.
Throughout the next few years,
Hirohito made many public appearances.
He taught,
bombed out cities and inspected new factories.
Now he dressed in a suit and tie and looking more like a prime minister from an
emperor Hirohito.
His image was now reshaped into the symbol of the wells to do Japanese middle
class success story.
He was what the ordinary Japanese man could strive to be if you worked hard
enough free of his imperial duties.
The former emperor now had time to indulge his passion for biology.
In the ensuing decades,
Sarah Hito faded into the backgrounds of Japanese significance.
He was increasingly seen as a symbol of the old Japan,
the new Japan.
It was focused on industrialization,
consumerism,
and a strong work ethic.
His value was now as a public relations figure who was occasionally wheeled out
and sent around the world on goodwill tours,
still the specs of the passing of the emperor in the mid 19 eighties,
so an outpouring of grief and profound respect among all classes and all ages in
Japan,
but also there was the question of war responsibility,
but the consensus was and remains that Hirohito bore a measure of moral
responsibility for the atrocities that were committed in China and through the
Far East in the 19 thirties and forties,
the ends.
It ultimately came on January the seventh,
19,
89,
the result of God,
no cancer.
The funeral was attended by representatives of 163 nations.
Many have mixed feelings about being bad because of the war responsibility
question great persons.
Prince Philip later said that he overcame his conscience by not bowing before
the emperor.
His casket simply nodding his head slightly,
so I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday won't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the race,
and as always,
thank you for watching.